this game does have an epilepsy warning
to those watching
it says there's an epilepsy warning as
you're launching the game so if you guys
have issues with epilepsy please uh
take note that there is a warning for
that on this game
good morning okay hi i think i've muted
myself i'm gonna do the tutorial this is
surgeon simulator too by the way in case
anyone's curious
i keep thinking it's hand simulator but
i gotta remember it's not
oh why would anybody be able to jump in
this game
ow i don't know how to play oh
accurate okay whatever what am i doing
some kind of a tutorial
but i don't know what heaving troubles
with the doors i'm afraid the unlock
button
should be nearby
interesting okay
oh interesting
excellent question you're a natural
oh i suppose i would have been better
that's not right
how would you put your hand down
no this ain't right
sorry i'm being immature i am sorry
about the mess
uh-huh bob
i think it is are they all the other
guys doing the tutorial as well what
oh that's how you do it
[Music]
oh
interesting it's oddly intuitive it's
not hand simulator that's what i gotta
remember
any game that's not hand simulator is
gonna be perfectly fine
because that game was intentionally
garbage so this actually feels like it
controls kind of nicely
that door requires an id card i'm sure i
left mine around there somewhere
why did you leave everything around here
for me and not necessarily for something
that i could
actually use why do you have three id
cards that doesn't make any sense at all
whatever who cares i'm dr pamela preston
one of the founders
you'll be the very first to trial our
surgeon simulator training program
all right cool it's literally a surgeon
simulator
huh all right cool also this game does
have a multiplayer mode so there is a
purpose of this we're just going to get
through the tutorial and then we're
going to go to everything else
hello am i missing some important story
is that a
poop pan i think that's the technical
term for that excuse me
pardon me
i'm gonna break everything as i said
it's a work in progress
uh-huh yeah sure everything seems to be
a work in progress is that jello
there flan there that i can bust through
this that's so bad i can bust through
this
and i bust through it i mean clip
through the universe and actually make
it into this room
oh i didn't bring the id card i'm always
losing those things
yeah good thing you have 10 000 of them
huh
don't ask me why i want to bring this i
just do
hello this is bob a barnachier local
you'll get to know him very well indeed
through the course of the program
the surgeon simulator training program
is a groundbreaking new approach to
surgery
real patience real conditions simulated
scenarios
soon you'll be able to tackle all kinds
of medical emergencies with ease and
confidence
it's all terribly exciting we'll start
your training with a quick heart
transplant
easy
i'm not sure why that door's locked me
neither julian
why is that door locked
okay well i guess we'll have to come
back later
let's try something a little different
onwards
what do you mean onwards this game is
what oh
that cannot be me the litter
legitimately cannot be me
why am i in a tube
[Laughter]
okay cool hey tutorial done hey guys hey
how's it going dude hey i just finished
this tutorial i think
all three all three
electrons there's three things
you have to do what uh a leg and two
arms or something i've never even done
anything yet it didn't let me do
anything
oh all right i'll be back then all right
cool see it
bye bye all right so we're still going
on this all right here we go hey
what do you got for me where's my mallet
i don't know why i wanted to bring the
mallet i just wanted it okay i was
hoping to drum on some ribs or something
i don't know
duck yeah
this is my friend now this is my friend
hey
that gadget with the screen is a
diagnostic scanner it'll tell you what's
wrong with your patient
lesson one keep a close eye on bob's
blood level
big leads
right leg rip it off
his right am i right all right you uh
actually hang on you observe the
operation
wink there you go oh frick
off and put it in the chute uh yeah okay
i don't like the way that duck is
looking at me
because it is definitely looking at me
i hate him all right uh his right
okay got it let's get a good get a good
leg i am so strong
i was expecting this to actually work
yeah
[Laughter]
that's all right oh that's not right at
all
okay he's fine not losing a lick of
blood
oh my god no no no
blood level he's losing it oh no put it
back
okay oh no
right leg i punched it off that's fine
in you go buddy great
well this is horrible use a yellow
syringe to stop bob's bleeding
huh oh never mind we'll patch him up for
you
rip his right leg off and put it in the
chute well he died
all right cool thank you i guess i got a
hurry or some stupid crap like that
right in the dick in the dick get it in
the dick
he needs more there we go
that's what i call good
what am i doing lag
[Music]
kobe
lovely work remember when you rip off an
appendage bob will bleed out very
quickly
let's continue so why am i ripping off
his legs all right whatever anyway okay
carry on i guess you're coming with me
okay it looks like bob's low on blood
why do you want
a red syringe first why is he low on
blood why would he be low on blood first
actually he seems fine on blood all
right you you watch from right there
point
uh nose
top bob up with the red syringe i don't
think it's supposed to go directly into
the brain
his arms seemed to be already rather
than just ripping off
a limb use a little more finesse this
time
why don't you grab a saw why don't you
wearing technique
grab the saw straight on if you need to
realign your grip
drop it and try again align the saw with
the cutting line
place it down gently and sew back and
forth until the limb drops off
sure we're gonna go with sure if you use
the saw bob will bleed out much more
slowly
which arm did you say which arm right
arm
you got it okay
perfect ev everything about this is
perfect
can i thank you his right arm off and
pop a fresh one on
working on it this is easy this is going
so good
maybe i should go this angle would make
a lot more sense oh yeah that's that's
really doing it
okay pop for uh arm
okay arm
i probably should have popped i thought
that was gonna be like some kind of a
shoot that i needed to dump it in buddy
i didn't put it on right remember for a
successful appendage transplant
bob must have all of his limbs and head
attached
let's proceed not the left arm it's the
uh
finally an organ transplant remember to
check the diagnostic scanner
to perform a successful transplant the
sick organs must come out
the rest of the organs are optional
crush the ribs with something heavy to
get at his lungs
grab a scalpel and stick it into a lung
to remove it
i can't just rip organs out but bob will
bleed out much more quickly
uh-huh okay i'm assuming it's probably
smart for me to get the
organs ready for transplant by having
them
over here okay and then i just gotta rip
them out
right is that what you said that's what
they oh wait no was
wait was the good organ which one was a
good organ it's probably fine can i have
this can i have this can i have this can
i have this
crack the ribs remove the old lungs i
forgot
i forgot i forgot i forgot i forgot i'm
coming buddy
now
[Music]
i'm sorry that it had to be like this
i'm sorry that we had to say goodbye
i'm sorry that we didn't get our chance
i'll always remember you
old friend
farewell all right whatever let's move
on
bob and wade are probably waiting for me
okay what was i doing rip it off
okay rip rip rip rip
rip letter rip remove these ribbons
rip in some new ones i wish i had my
mallet
this will do thunk flank flunk
flamp that'll do good enough is he
bleeding
not even a little bit move the old ones
pop in some new ones
uh okay long
lot long is this a good long it's bad
lung how can i tell
pop in some new ones okay yeah that's
good enough
bleeding a bit but not that much okay
other other
other okay
well this seems pretty simple a lot
easier than the first game i'll tell you
what
beautifully done remember removing an
organ with a tool will result in much
lower blood loss
we hope to open up the mysteries of
surgery to the world
we believe anyone no matter their
background can become a surgeon
as you can see all it takes is a can do
attitude okay good oh
god jesus christ hey
hi how you doing this is what the duck
saw every time
horrible absolutely horrible hey hi
oh hey sorry loser it took me well am i
done
i did the legs and lungs are you to the
point where you can get into the lobby
yeah i see a i see a mirror uh okay so
you can customize your character there
bob can see an invite you can join us
now
okay that's that all sounds great
hitting on pick one of four characters i
know you love character customization
yep yeah i know you really care about
that so take your time uh-huh
i want to see if i can just what did you
guys do did you guys
move the duck the what what the duck
move the duck is that code your door was
locked until just now
yeah we can't we couldn't go in your
room so your room is however your room
is
did you guys move the duck oh no you
didn't okay cool did you make a friend
oh no my jello is on the floor okay cool
all right i'm ready to go guys
i think we must enter our tubes enter
our tubes
okay for what to do it to do what said
go
what do you think what are we doing chat
went o for two they thought bob would be
heather they thought mark would be the
character i'm playing as
okay why why would they think that bob
probably the glasses you the mustache
sounds suspicious to me spacious to me
as well hey you guys
look at how strong i am look at i can't
see the narcissism in the mustache is
the two answers
narcissism and the muscles so your
character is narcissistic
according to cinemasins if i'm carrying
around an apple to make myself look more
like an [ __ ]
so oh wait i thought i thought wade was
the other person i'm sorry i have no
idea who
i'm the chica are you prepared yeah i'm
ready did you guys select the level
already are we good yeah i'm ready
wait get in your tube i'm ready why is
this the transportation mechanism
because tubes oh i'm not lined up oh i
was not lined up with the opening
i straight up have a concussion from
wanging my head on the edge of that
that opening that's okay you don't need
a brain to do surgery apparently
i don't like that the guy on the table
is named bob i don't appreciate that
well i mean that's how it's been the
whole time so i don't
i don't like that can i just be honest i
don't appreciate that
yeah you can you can be as honest as you
want it doesn't change anything
um i don't know if you guys noticed mark
you probably don't care but if you
complete the missions
and they do like the secondary
objectives you unlock more cosmetics and
stuff
wow i care in a certain amount of time
limiting loss of blood
yeah we're going to get that is that a
baby oh it's a bear i thought it was a
baby
no it's a perfectly good baby look at
the baby i thought it was the heller you
want about it
yeah let's find a baby baby look at my
baby here mark mark wait oh what wait a
minute
oh no i got you come here baby
come here baby this is adorable this is
wholesome
this is good anybody see a card i found
a card
what are we looking for card got it done
we're looking for the best well i have
an id card right here
too late it's too late
the way you guys kind of lag through
everything it's just very juttery
look i just do i put my card and not
these books
i don't care to help at all
here lady what are we doing here bob's
got a bad heart
uh can i just pound his ribs open with
my fist dude pound
try why not oh oh no don't grab the ribs
pound them really really get in there
oh oh god oh i got his blue
what did you give me that oh he's
bleeding out uh um
i have an axe mark what's blue do you
guys know what's blue
no way where's the stickers where's the
prickers
the prickers there we go no you got to
get the you got to get the prickers
yeah we're going for the quickest
what's up mark do you know where the
heart is yeah sure
it's in this this area you gotta really
go for this area
trying to get wade can you you doing it
man that head was sturdy did you get
this head off
yeah dude the head is where the heart is
here i'm going to put some blood in
where the heart is
mark i think you're not helping as much
as i mean like
i don't think this is mark's fault i
think we all have our own shortcomings
here yeah exactly
hang on i'm very tall oh you know what i
should probably put the blood in the
head hole
what oh shoot i look so sad i vote we
try again
yeah that'd be nice yeah that's a good
that's a good vote yeah all right i
think we should definitely
make sure mark doesn't get the ax all
right i just wanted to
see what would happen just uh well i
think you knew what would happen i
didn't know what would happen
i think you knew science is about
exploration and discovery i write down
my conclusions
and then we're good you know for
somebody who suggested we rip the hearts
out of people and eat them earlier you
kind of suck at getting the heart
well i mean no i wasn't trying i wasn't
no you didn't get me you didn't get me
yet i wasn't trying to get the heart i
was
trying to cut off all the limbs i got
the id cards this time nerds
i thought yeah i thought you got it last
time there was an id card on top of the
spot bob fox of biles but i got the fox
the biles
you you got the biles but that's the
idea guys
secret secret okay you gotta let me go
first my god you are just the worst you
are
literally my secret you're literally the
worst
we're inspired give me a boost i'm
discovering my secret you are literally
you are literally the worst you know
mark you're right you want
some of my secret food you are literally
the worst i discovered
you're literally the worst why aren't
you participating in my life
literally the worst you know that's not
the entire thing
but there's more secret oh there is more
secrets
literally mark wait it's my secret let
me go first nope
aha it's so amazing it's incredible oh
wow
wait you're really on me right now i am
literally the worst wait a minute my
dudes
mark what have you found my dudes my
secret senses
are tingling so intensely we need to
find like a button
or something okay we need to find
there's got to be like something out
here
there there must be a button yeah
there's some kind of a button
or something of the like screw bob
forget bob forget about
he's fine he's he'll live for this is
all that's fine huh what's this
there's some kind of a button there's
got to be a button right well so there's
an id thing on this door
do we have any more id cards well just
bring the other one
doesn't it no that's no that's a
different doctor that's different
there's got to be some kind of a there's
something you're sure it's a different
doctor
yeah you need to leave the id card on
the station or else it doesn't function
oh i can lock you guys in there whoa
oh look don't believe
[Music]
hey can we get up to that door lord yeah
go for it there's lore i found the id
card but
here we go here bob i found this id card
i'm bringing it to you you take this
door where are you oh hey take it okay
there's another secret over here too
soon to plan ahead i want to see a
secret
ow sometimes these doors these doors
like to kick you real hard
wait a minute oh some kind of button
over here
yeah trying to that's that thing you
were asking about
yeah ah ah
oh very good stack ah i'm stuck help
i think you did yeah did i push the
button is it pushed i don't know if that
counts as a button or not i don't know
if it does anything
yeah but i think we probably need to
move these bookshelves i think that's
the thing
is there some secret in the bookshelf i
don't know but they're set in the wall
it's too suspicious
everything about is suspicious did you
go away let me let me give you a boost
let me give you a boost
oh thank you why didn't you just go up
this way
wait why didn't you just go this way all
right i'm going to do the mark's way
because i'm an idiot i hate that you're
right i hate this well
why do you hate that i'm right ugh here
i'm going to bring some light
okay i've got the light source okay
what oh apparently i can't do this mark
how'd you do this what are you i
am stuck what do you mean how'd you get
up there i can't i can't
jump i can't oh never mind i did it what
what is over there what's it say it's
just like i got the light source guys
it's a sticky that's a face i don't know
here look at the book
is there anything on the book that's
nice well about the back what's the best
is all blocked out it's just it's like
censored out
what do you mean it's censored out it's
called alien it's not
yeah it's just lines oh well that's dumb
all right there's no secret well
guess who's trapped in here nerds
no no i guess excuse me excuse me excuse
me
okay there's an eyeball all right did we
find all the secrets oh wait the door i
put the id on the door and i didn't even
go checking out
yeah i think that's just to get the
heart anyone want an eye oh wait that's
not i used to work with eyes i would
take an eye there you go
the door is the door's not open oh it's
both things are required to get into the
door
we mean both things what are things we
need a heart
and the key to get into the door a heart
and the key
well you guys see the big red button
here right one that i pressed to get bob
up here before
that's not what we mean right now there
it is mark will you come help
i'm here i think it's surgery time i
think it's surgery o'clock
there's got to be a button around here
all right i'm going to wang this button
all right wang away oh i'm going to do
it
you ready sure
before we do anything let me let me play
a little ditty
uh-huh
it kind of works
oh god okay like you broke your eyes you
knocked his arm off
what how did i put it back put it back
on um put it back on
he's bleeding he's bleeding he's
there we go okay suck that suck that
baby right back on there yeah
no he's not actually okay yeah arms are
naturally uh
naturally they just come right off what
the hell yeah
and they alright so which one of these
[ __ ] is the heart that's my question
i think it's under the lungs
so do we need to take the lungs out or
temporarily
we just shove them back in when we're
done uh guys i found something obscene
dude it's worse than it did his arm off
again ah freaking
no guys mark help what's up oh don't
show me that's you're gonna give me band
yeah i know might want a blood syringe
to get blood
do we have a blood syringe listen
oh what's the other objective here
huh take the heart although you open the
new door is there another one
i got the heart look oh
[Laughter]
that is so jiggly we didn't get wade
plus plus what under five and a half
minutes losing no blood damage you like
pot for
it's like it's like a helmet oh that's
the a plastic okay
there was a secret there and i was about
to find it
you're on the verge margaret you're on
the very top on the cusp
yeah i was cusping cosmin bro i was
about to cusp
i'm gonna cusp yeah that
that is what i was gonna say julian this
one should be tip top
i find this offensive to imply that i
could somehow be improved
with surgery i don't like that i don't
know why you're projecting so much this
isn't about you there are other people
named bob around here
no there are not don't worry guys i'm
gonna check literally every filing
cabinet
that's probably worth your time hey they
made these they made these for some
reason so there's got to be some secret
in here
i know there's secret there's lore going
on here loremaster markiplier in the
house
the worst dj name ever okay well it's
not that bad number one and it's
the worst it is dj name
hey they've got a book about my career
kind of just being rude here what does
it say i got a whole book about my
career
filler failure
yeah you know what you're right you're
right hey uh
what do you see wade i see a darkness
enveloping
light but the light is already being
infiltrated by another darkness
oh wow okay um holy [ __ ] come on
come on you know you like me to just
tickle you with the needle
come on why can't i not get through here
too big mark for once you know what it's
like to be too tall
it's not fun it's not fun i gotta admit
it's not fun how much
how much blood can this man's have
that's my question
he's pretty low as it is he's got he's
only got 800 blood
all right i'm on a mission no he's got
1800 blood
no no i read it i know how numbers are
apparently not
sir come here come to daddy
oh that's the spot it's if that says 800
blood
is there a way to shrink ourselves down
definitely not that i know of
i think she's playing grounded over here
the more important thing is the secrets
guys i don't know
come to the bathroom mark there's a
secret beer in the middle of something
the secret is going to be wade's butt no
i can't
oh look at this i
will literally kill you man i will i
will go no hang on
mark i found a secret i can't i found i
found a
hang on i caught a secret here no are
you gonna put these boxes up here
will you help me with the boxes or what
i won't you know i won't
i'm not going to i'm not going to
entertain i found something cool why
won't you just let me have that i
am not participating in anything of this
and i'm not a part of this
there is lore here and you're just
getting yeah i'm getting it
there's a secret in the bathroom there's
no secret in the bathroom
there's a secret out here for sure mark
i don't know why you're being such a
naysayer about this
oh naysayers come look in the toilet i
really don't want to look at your poop
wig it's not actually in the toilet
look right there all right there's gotta
be better stuff to find this secret
it's not pleasant since mark won't help
me with my secret uh
and do it on my own oh
yeah perfect secret was the paint
perfect hey ducky
perfect yes listen mark
just because you can't appreciate how
perfectly
perfect my secret hunt is going uh-huh
mustard
no thank you okay
i just used the mustard wade mustard me
bob i actually don't think you're gonna
get through that hole
seems to have an impediment to progress
wait maybe maybe it's a maybe it's a
game maybe we need a dunk in it
just nba jams on that all right that's
bigger than i thought it would be
there's a button on the other side of it
oh there's a button you got to drop
throw something in it you gotta throw
something on it you guys i don't know
but who just said that secret bomb
there's balls the balls are the balls
are too big i
don't wanna i don't wanna let you get
too excited about that
the ball slam dunk baby this is just
brutal
how amazing i am oh yeah
this is how we do that oh someone seems
to be upon me oh my god
oh my god i'm amazing
the secret way to get the limbs we need
oh okay yeah this this doesn't this
doesn't seem like a secret
i think we need to pass the arm through
to get minimal blood loss
well he only has 800 balloons so i'll be
i'll stand by here
you guys start slicing those
what who wants to do the ripping who
wants to do the blood hang on i've got
the saw
let me let me be sawdust before you saw
where's the
are there syringes in here dum-dum in
there dum-dum
all right all you gotta do is pass me
the arm and i'll give you something but
you gotta tell me which arm it is
before you pass it because each one goes
into a different hole which one are we
doing we're doing
we're doing both
arm's coming baby arm's coming hey thank
you get it got it
okay get ready for the pass okay arm
is fully extended here we go take it
baby
get get take it hang on take it don't be
gonna get you're pushing it back
all right yeah push your foot i'll back
off back up there we go
how's he doing wade great i mean how am
i doing
great how are we doing
great slap it right becoming good okay
great say great
we good everything good we're good we're
good wade you're just standing there
shaking are you okay
all right ready for a surgery number
dose wait
we're at 4 000 blood okay you're just
standing there okay you're moving okay
i got myself oh that's not right uh what
is that
okay he doesn't need that he doesn't
need that that's fine nope no did you
get his br
well that's oh this lower intestine i
thought that was brain it's
fine yeah
let me just apply a little bit more
pressure and you're going to feel it
it's gone baby all right add them in the
dick
ready to receive this is a right arm
correct okay that didn't go very far a
little more please
there we go all right cool got it plap
i'm actually going to give him some
blood see if that helps
he doesn't need blood never mind we
can't give blood bam
perfect nice nice
surgical revolution i like to think of
my life-saving procedures
from this one hi hey oh what are you
talking about
hey oh oh
it's a mask with eyebrows or what is
that that's a mask with eyebrows you got
it right
what did we make under seven oh okay we
did it again we know how to get the
thing unlocked i
we're just really taking it all in yeah
there's lore
to be found
no one has tried to kill anyone yet why
would we try to kill anyone that'd be
horrible
yeah well i mean each other amongst
ourselves
we're working as a team did you just
show us what we got just like
and then go on very important to the
unique nature of our facility
thank you okay thank you pm
pam yeah
thank you bomb don't you need an arm to
get through here
oh no guys i got an arm door why does
she guess
what does she guess so much stuff
sometimes why do they have doors
hanging on i got a dropping arm i got a
little you guys want to see my show
all right mark look you want to see a
good [ __ ] yeah i would do
oh oh i think there might be a secret
sort of i see it i see a
i see a drop in i thought i thought you
were about to do the ending of the tour
oh
[Laughter]
all right what are we doing here
gentlemen we need an army there's arms
and there's there's arms in this room we
just got to go get it yeah but if you
look at the top of the room with the
arms
there's one of those doors like a secret
door i think it's just operation
no no it's a secret mark mark the one
who hasn't found
any secrets of course he wouldn't in the
operating room there's one of those
doors too
i'm going to open the arm door okay
your dear brother's old office what did
you do
hey look i found a way into the
operating room
oh oh that's the door i just saw
it banana mark
yes oh i found a ducky you like the
ducky yeah
that was my ducky i'll bring you ducky
no i don't need the ducky i had enough
here mark
no mark now these book shelves look
awfully removable
no here hey thanks man but i i had one i
had one
here i had it mark here i had one i had
one i
had one i don't wanna ladder
don't move it don't move don't move
don't move it don't move it don't move
it stop moving it i'm
moving it down one is don't move
anything don't move it don't move it
who moved it don't move it don't move it
don't move it
don't move it you do it why are you so
bad at this
look it's harder than it looks don't
move it i don't believe you
move it there we go all right i'm gonna
do this in two jumps
ah i see whoops it does
go down here it does
wait wait give me a boost oh my god
i mean it's not going to be any surprise
it just goes to the arm room
how did you do that mark you're a wizard
i am bra yeah i see it's not so
easy hey i'm trying to give you a
compliment okay
it's not so easy here let me get this
out i'm never gonna compliment you again
you never compliment me anyway so what
does it matter
wait oh okay oh never mind
hey what we can get in i know that's
what i said when i got up here we can
get in now
a mark should we do the surgery yeah i
don't know what the benefit of going
into the arm room would be from there
but that
is the thing oh hey duck
yeah yeah
i'm stuck hello i had this struggle in
the bathroom earlier i know
cap yeah i'm gonna hit this button and
let's do this all right let's do this
what are we doing
surgery i am sorry to report this all
right i'm here
i'm in the hole ready to take whatever
you need to give me what
there's so many voices what are we
seeing we need to do his right leg his
left arm and it's some kind of middle
part organ uh his blue or is
lower looks like it's blue what is that
blue usually the large intestines are
below the small intestines i don't know
what that's about
here wait do you stay over there the
game devs are here we need to know their
secrets
why are they here they're watching why
all right well where
do you have way do you have arms uh i
can take right leg left arm and
large intestine okay i'm going to do
right leg
mark let me get something yeah yeah yeah
i'm i'm standing by
i'm ready oh apparently i'm in are you
in
oh delicately delicately
yeah and put a little force on there
yeah you're doing any
little strokes yeah that's getting her
this looks very
i cannot tell if he's bleeding or not so
i'm just doing this intermittently
there we go and i'm assuming he's good
he's good he's good he's good good let
me just give wade the little stump
all right i'm gonna do his arm while
we're here hang on well hang on let me
give him
let me give him a booster shot oh oh oh
get him
i got you a leg for my peeping hole here
we go all right
thank you thank you yeah you're welcome
you enjoy that i'm gonna go back to
people
now slap this [ __ ] on there yep
whip me just get hang on i'm getting it
you got it
that's getting it you're literally
getting it come on man
there we go and he's full of what wait
i'm about to bring you a blue
thing i'm ready oh that leg is not on
there i hope you know
oh whoa hey it was on there there we go
mark he's going to need some juice i'm
juicing dude i am god
he is juiced up juicing him up yeah i'm
going to give him i'm going to give him
our usual injection here
you're good you're good it's it it's in
all right all right so then it's left
arm yeah so you want to do some sawing
marking no i'm good
i got the syringe all right going and
going for arm
i want this too oh that's not
cooperating
a little all over the place there's a
little aggressive i think i've run this
thing out of juice already i don't know
how
yeah yeah good well oh that's
a spicy one oh it's fret's out of here
all right we are out of blood except
there's one on the ground excuse me
can't you push the button no i pushed
the button there's a limit man
in the way here wait come on get it wait
hurry up wait
here okay i'm coming i'm coming hurry up
there you go
don't you hear the dramatic organs they
are kind of dramatic
there we go clean off the smudge from my
breath
there we go of surgery
well done well done
let's continue
[Laughter]
yeah wow hey
hey
dude killing it right now wow that we're
pretty good
sorry i i i neglected not to press the
button but we're pretty good
i haven't pressed the button a single
time i just realized that existed
okay and there you go that's what we get
this is what you got
at the end of the night
how many is this all the same mission
how many is this
i got this for you oh thank you enjoy
that
perfect perfect it's like you're natural
it's like you've been doing it your
whole life
very bad knees i know that's a real lie
it's reality stares my nemesis
you all right there gramps yep doing
great
lord please pretend you're not seeing
this
oh um oh frick the eyes mark what you
doing
lore look i found a thing nor
lower lore
oh wait we need another one wait wait
before we do that one
this more lore
oh no this is not secrets this is just a
different place
more lore not lore but game
lore oh no this doesn't mount up nicely
like i thought it would
lore boop no bob
found i'm right here thank you very much
mark are you um where you at bro hello
are you in the door are you in the lord
or lord
mark yes what's up that's not you
wait why are you uh why are you is that
where mark is
wait are you completely by the way wade
oh
yeah i was trying to say we were in the
hole follow us over here
why am i always muted the wrong time
lore no other way hey hey mark
dang it i just oh there was something at
the end of this oh
oh you're are you good
there was something at the end of this
conveyor belt and i got the lore
wait a minute you want me to argue
yeah oh wait no wait there was something
that fell down the other way
wait yeah that comes out in the surgery
wait you're literally stuck there if i
don't
throw the switch i but
i
it was all of his own doing it was
literally his own doing can i reach
the oh no i can't what's going on i
really can't get out of there
high fives casey neistat wave
you don't want to pull that lever for me
no is it this one
yeah you just you just smack it that way
oh oh yeah yeah there you go
no is that what you want to do and then
yeah
you smack it so delicately no i think we
should just leave him there
and uh we should go do the same come on
wait we open the bar come back this way
you can get out this way
wow he believed me that's weird oh my
god
wait can you open that bar huh no uh no
way oh okay come on all right all right
all right all right
all right all right all right all right
hang on i'm having some real trouble
with this
yes a free no i'm not free
wait did you did you really not get out
i left you i lost you like two seconds
oh there's another conveyor we gave him
a shot we didn't give him a shot
for this well let's just see where he's
at let's see what's going on here
hey excuse me let me just get this out
of the way where
oh there he is some kind of idiot
trapped over here
wait here wait take my check my box
wait don't don't fill me up oh god here
does this help here wait take take this
[Laughter]
all right if i throw this switch is it
just gonna be getting sucked in
is it it's your box hang on i'm gonna
really smack this bad boy in here slam
that thing in there
okay let me just hammer this in please
what else do we have what else do we
have hang on i don't want i don't want
anything to happen we can flood him
no no i mean i want to i want to stack
stuff up in front of uh
in front of that and see uh why do you
want to do that exactly
i just want to i don't want you to get
out accidentally i want your i want your
home to be your safe space with yeah
okay i actually wonder if you could get
out that box on the other hand
mark do the do switch the conveyor belt
i want to see what happens i'm standing
down here holding the box
okay hang on you can do it i believe in
you
oh it's got speed controls oh no this
one's not moving i can't
the bottom box i'm giving him full speed
full speed oh no
i'm holding i'm holding i'm holding on
i'm losing it mark i'm losing it i'm
here to help
when i clip into the box i can see
wade's suffering
hey this is what was on this there's
bread wait i'm giving you a piece of
food
okay
oh hey brad hey all right are we ready
i spent a long time setting that up
thank you okay all right
let's set a little bit that's not how
that's not how it was
it's perfect shall i karate chop this
surgery into existence
yes yeah let's play the actual game i
guess
so who's gonna tell me what they need so
i can drop some organs on the conveyor
belt um
we need a left leg uh and some
middle stomach what are those got a cart
there's a leg on the way
what else hang on hang on you gotta get
his chest open hang on heart
heart stomach how many times
anything too drastic there bob uh to
yourself um how about some syringes
uh whatever okay do you know where they
are
we already found those there's
dispensers in there oh you're right
you're right you're right you're right
hang on let's try it here he goes no he
decides oh that might be one of the
things i need to no that's not a thing i
need to replace mark
get this orange get this right here i
gotta get us i'm getting a
there needs to be a gurney i needed okay
well that's
lost cause no i don't need i don't need
long suede he just doesn't need like i
don't know what this is
is this candy i think i found some candy
all right i'm gonna get rid of that get
rid of the stomach brains
oh come on these tables really okay
mark are you coming with those three i
gotta get the table
first mark um uh
mark
where am i where am i i'm pretty sure
that was mark's fault
i'm just gonna throw out there that that
was not an ideal surgery
i don't know where the syringes that i
was calling for
i was trying to get a table ready
i don't think you needed this table i
think you needed to bring me some
syringes
all right fine you know what whatever i
replaced the fuse in the place you stole
the fuse from uh-huh
yeah and hey uh just now i just gotta
figure out a way
to get up get up
come here well yeah you saw the hole in
the ceiling here right pick it up
huh i think you're going to be proud of
me i am proud of you
you have my proudest what are you doing
you're getting all your syringes out
here yeah
yeah but apparently there's an up you
know wade's on like
you know how he is well the whole time
he's been all secret secrets that's like
yeah i know it's like shut up that's
what i was saying like just shut up
let's play the game yeah we're here to
do surgery it's called surgeon simulator
not a secret simulator idiot she's an
idiot anyway i'm gonna unmute and talk
to him now hey wade
oh wow this is cool yeah man
that's nuts so cool hey buddy uh you
think that maybe we should like you know
play the game
a little bit that might be how dare you
you stay in here
and you think about that why don't you
okay
uh hang on i'm gonna lift this to you
[ __ ] are we
not we're ready baby we're ready let's
do
this sure there's still syringes in here
let's do
that table ready table we don't need a
table what do you think we need a table
yeah who would you who would have a
table yeah i'm kind of
where my mind is being [ __ ]
come on watch your language okay i did i
said la
surgery o'clock baby oh hey i see you uh
took my job of dropping organs on a belt
yeah real tough yeah i know how much
this must have really trusted you
yeah okay all right anyway we got all
the organs don't worry i'll keep doing
the real
hard work real dog
oh hey why did you drop me my syringe is
on the ground my dude
i had those nicely they were on a table
actually this is uh this is not as
effective as i would have hoped
what is it what are you used to trying
to get through these
rails yeah let's be let's be smart about
this
what if i excuse me surgeon coming
through is this uh
is this just getting it
that leg is stuck in there i don't know
if that's a common occurrence
i'll go in and grab it too late what's
wrong
with the solution i've sent
guys we don't even need more legs it's
fine i got it
so it's really some kind of hammer
device
wait wait did that get it yeah yeah it's
out okay
i told you you cleared this oh there we
go
is anyone else that's an arm is anyone
watching man
uh
if you could please uh uh we've lost two
thousand blood but blood is stopped now
if you were paying attention you would
have noticed that it started at
2800 idiot thousands of bloodlines all
right
so what are we yoinking out of here
heart and stomach stomach
okay the blue one that guy no
that's the large intestine okay okay
this seems to be our believers
okay wait did you not just see that i
was already doing that one so why would
you put
more antibodies i didn't see which one
you grabbed i was just
helping you weren't actually that's
maybe all right
now would be the time way to do whatever
you were doing
my professional opinion is give him give
this man some more blood trying to get
the blood but it's just hard to grab
there we go let's get that in there hang
on i'm trying to get my hands on this
little heart muscle
i need
just needs stomach all right he's good
hang on hold on hang on
well the leg's really getting away from
me here hang on get that leg back
oh i knocked the other leg out and then
there goes the scanner okay
normal it should there okay
oh well wade listen
my man you don't have any police on a
surgery or surgery i'm gonna kalima you
you don't even know how to pronounce it
right kalima kalama
kalama damn it i think we were pretty
close on that we were pretty close yeah
yeah if
if a dumbo over there would stop
slapping around
you're not that bad mark stop being so
hard on yourself
maybe someone else should be the surgeon
should i i want to be a nurse
i would like to be a nurse please i will
take over the surgeon's role
finally like you deserve this for some
reason
actually yeah about time eight years of
medical right you don't even know how to
set up a nurse's station i wouldn't
do a nurse's station because i'm the
surgeon
how can you call yourself a surgeon if
you aren't even
the the first evolution of a surgeon
that's it's not
pokemon here it's it's
i had like a great great grandpa who was
assertive i'm like a surgeon twice
removed or something
that's definitely not a thing
i'm going to drop stuff on the conveyor
belt ah you're going to drop the right
stuff
uh you need a heart right leg yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
yeah let's go with yeah i think this is
a it's either a stomach or a
penis i don't know what this is it's
definitely i don't know if we should
have weighed identifying body parts in
there
all right surgeon your nurse is ready
yeah yeah
i'll be right there uh-huh sir surgeon
man
uh-huh
are we ready to start this
i've had my shots i'm good to go let's
get this
yeah all right we're looking at an old
left leg uh
ectomy nurse
oh i'm ready i'm ready be ready i'm
ready
okay good i'm ready ready and then
normally slicing
currently slicing and uh injecting in
the neck
and
this is a left leg indeed i know it from
the smell
stop doctor let me inject this man whoa
wait a minute oh no
oh dear what kind of nurse am i can you
please
give him some blood i'm i'm getting it
i'm here to help
have i ever told you about moe's
hardness scale i am familiar with your
affinity for bose hardness scale
yes uh in any way yeah you would know
that hardness scale
only the thing on the same hardness
level can break the thing that it's on
so obviously i've gotten this skull to
break the bone
wait why do you okay you have yellow i
have yellow you get red
you could have used the partially used
syringe
a nurse a nurse would know that look
once something's been used
you you recycle it you go straight to a
new one listen how's that
bose gardness scale working out for you
supremely effective thank you
perfect see how it's worked out all
right be ready with you just use uh
billy's skull okay i don't know who
billy is
and i don't care is our friend i don't
care forgotten about them don't care
all right we are all right please stop
the bleeding i'm um
i'm behind you doctor but it's not
creepy don't worry about it stop the
bleeding
i've got my blood done i'm ready to rock
all right
where's the new heart it's over here on
the floor next to the bread
all right get ready with the bleed
stoppie and blood give
yeah i'm mom remember i'm itching to
stab you here we go
and where's the new korean nuts on the
ground thank you that's very
good on the ground look it's a clean
floor okay i don't know what you want
mm-hmm yeah what's one of those
practitioner school
look i got nothing wrong with nurses
why do you hate nurses so much look i
don't
but hey shut up i'm sorry
what hey all right take your blood wait
a minute uh
you guys seen what i'm saying i know
you're creeping around
oh ruining everything dr josh was in the
robert oh robert uh bob i'm guessing
oh my god robert's short for bob
hey bob it's me hey
look at us
see that's what happens when you have a
competent surgeon yeah you know what
when you're right you're right
i sent julian in to tidy up in here so
this one should go very smoothly
building this place has been difficult
certain friendships are
particularly difficult i know how that
goes everything is fine
well certainly we'll be fine oh i wasn't
muted right jillian
yeah hey mark yeah what's up secrets
no way listen listen there's no time for
secrets we got to get down to business
it's about business this is a business
secret everything else so it's going to
be run efficiently and optimizationally
okay you all feel optimizationally yeah
uh-huh the hell does that even mean
listen i'm gonna do my catchphrase in
this game and you're gonna listen to it
okay
all right shut up nurse i'm a
doctor okay that's pretty good right
uh why is that what is that at all
that's my catchphrase that's my
catchphrase
it's my catchphrase shut up first no
marker does a lot better than you
that that's not the way it's said i'm
just saying that's my catchphrase i've
watched all the animateds and all the
surgeon sims and you say it with a lot
more venom
i don't say it with anything you've
changed why would i why would i say it
with any venom why would i use it
yeah new nice kill you is the worst you
cancel
i am a doctor
boo i'm just gonna get the patient up
here let's just get this started
i want to ride him do it okay whatever
man
do it oh all right well that's left arm
your feet should definitely not be in
the patient
whatever left arm is that the syringe is
over here and such a terrible
is this it or by left i meant right arm
did i say left
left that's right arm all right how
about we just do this rip it
and then i'll slap it rip and slap we'll
do it all right
no i'm not ready to slap i'll comfort
the patient
i'm not ready to slap all right we're
ready ready for the
the slide are you ready doctor yep rip
it you rip i slap
uh out kind of interfering with my grasp
of the arm grip it hang on
grip it all right ready yep
we're done record time baby that's what
i call a good surgery
well done well done halftime's all
around
him
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah oh wait here we go let me
we'll get to you
look at this
i'm gonna give you the old backhand i
didn't even feel anything
i did that's just because you're a
heartless monster
yes but i'm also rich and well paid as a
doctor right
now shall we get on with the next
surgery
um
oh up here secret door on top yes i know
i'm aware get the secrets go ahead
oh thanks for opening the secret dude
that's what i did for you
get out of here i don't want to drop
down i want to go over here i swear it
sounds like art schwarzenegger what is
yeah what is it help
wait stand over where that little glow
stick is stand over where that little
glow stick is
not that one the one on the side yeah
okay and then go back through this as i
pull it
okay okay where's it go there's
this is just there's nothing all right
see you around hey
see ya no see oh come on
where am i wait where am i all right
cool
oh hey guys i'm here look guys i'm here
i've got a power rod what do i do with
this nice rod what do i do what do i do
with this oh wait there's a there's a
power input
in here gotcha oh mark mark we can pry
this open
we can pry this open uh excuse me
maybe this will open when we uh put the
plug in or something
yeah yeah you know you did it yeah don't
worry i got it no strength did it mark
yeah i was in there
good job guys excellent job uh-huh we
did it
we did it wow wow wow
all right laura
call laura ma tell you what's going on
um i have the power thing and never mind
i'm
[Music]
uh we must need it to go down in the
hole there's more back here
something else back here can you move
this barrel for me i'm swanging the
wheel hang on oh there's
secret bread secret bread that's it
there's nothing else
okay uh i guess whether there's this
hole who wants to go in
someone with a fuse get in there uh
where that's not me
where i'm going in the hall
i'm going down am i going to die this is
where i get cracking okay now if i do
this to you a lot of body parts down
here a lot of body parts
how'd you how did you go down there i
fell you were
whoa what but wait wait let me in wait
keep going oh all right nice wait i
don't think you're making it
oh no it's monsters inc in here uh-oh
lore oh oh oh oh
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh dude wait he's in
the hole
baby uh guys look uh around the corner
did you see the shadow on the wall i see
it it's spooky
wait wait it's spooky come over here oh
hey
you're very oh can you can i pick these
oh look at me
guys look i got a light source no more
spooks for me
oh my god oh no no oh my god wait wait
wait no no no no it's great it's
incredible
no no stop oh stop me there you go
perfect
watch this
and wait excellent work man
uh-huh
uh-huh you hear that beautiful
it's it's really it's really good man
look i've been looking forward to this
all the time they put it in the game
damn it man we're musicians not doctors
okay you guys carry on i'll be here
[Music]
the bird the bird is so
free free the
bird the bird the bird
free the bird
i actually have never known what free
bird sounds like i
honestly could not tell you even how
it's so you nailed it okay didn't we
play
guitar hero 3 in college a bunch was
free bird on there
yes
oh that's free bird oh okay yeah the one
where he says free is a bird a lot
no that's free as a bird not free bird
very different he's free as a free bird
okay great
i'm free free bird
free the the song can only be named
after the only words that are in oh
this looks like some underground surgery
shifts yeah i had a fuse that in the
other room i brought it down
um never mind there might be one here
oh there's a fuse here's a fuse we got a
fuse i knew there would be a fuse
diagnostic there's a diagnostic and
there's a fuse
is there a second fuse hole i only see
the one
why oh
okay interesting did you get the
diagnostic
okay i'm coming good good please slap it
in
where do i slap it in on the uh well i
guess i'll just put a slap in the
basement
put it near him yeah yeah it only needs
to be near
that'll work oh here's the button blink
there's a button over here
oh no the button i just pressed opened
up this area with this big lever
oh look legs and stuff oh here's a
button how wait oh do that some more
that's how you get stuff off the
conveyor belt
okay how are we gonna convert about
running uh this
why is he gonna be noting our techniques
eject the legs wade
get him uh you guys are right i'm trying
to try to help wade here all right wait
now go uh guys we actually needed the
leg uh
the intestine we need the intestines
we're getting
pretty much everything yeah we got all
the parts over here in a neat pile on
the ground wait wait wait wait
we're ready wade ready wade get him yeah
you got any syringes or something um i
don't think we need those
okay oh yeah we got all the bits yep so
we're just going to yoink them out and
then we'll
have to get rid of the ribs to get the
blue intestine no you can get it without
getting rid of the ribs
yeah we can actually do both of these
great i'm pretty sure okay actually yeah
here i'll grab the large uh bob you just
yank we'll slap in he won't even bleed
i got i got a grip on the blue guy i'll
wait till you get both out and then
we'll just yeah get balls all right so
i'll do the yoinking yeah do both the
oinks
all right i will come in hot and wait
wait wait wait until he's done and then
and then and then and then yeah
yep okay here we go
get them in there doesn't matter make it
dirty wait you have
literally one job we've got about 10
seconds wait
wait oh my god shove it in oh boy oh my
god
wait how are you my god i don't know
just put it in
put put it put oh thank god okay first
try it's the pa system
but don't worry about that exactly it's
designed right
train our friends again what
surgical revolutions can be an emotional
business what this isn't pam
what do you what what what's up let's
get out of here spooky
hey a plus plus you're welcome by the
way a plussiest
all right oh i guess that's it oh that's
it yeah that's it for that's what all
they got for the
full release that was fun thank you for
the that was a lot of fun that was good
yeah that was pretty fun actually i was
curious how multiplayer would work for
this
i like the puzzle it works like the
added puzzle solution it works good it
works good
i want more secrets mainly just to
distract marks and bob and i can get the
work done
yeah definitely
[Music]
you